millions of americans were off today in  observance of juneteenth the nation's  newest federal holiday it marks the date  in 1865 when union troops arrived in  galveston texas to announce that all  enslaved people were free more than two  years after president abraham lincoln  issued the emancipation proclamation  there were some closures for the  observance of juneteenth post offices  the stock market federal buildings and  most banks closed today same thing for  the city of las vegas and north las  vegas city offices henderson and clark  county offices however were open  by the way fewer than half the states  recognize the holiday for their  government workers check out this map  here these are the states that do  recognize juneteenth for their workers  lawmakers here in nevada plus those in  some other states have not passed the  needed legislation to give their public  employees a paid day off